[CLOSED CAPTION - EN]
Discrimination against individuals with disabilities continues to be a
serious, pervasive social problem.
Discrimination against individuals with disabilities persists in such critical areas as-
Persists in such critical areas as employment, housing, public accommodations,
education, transportation, communication, recreation, institutionalization
health services, voting, and access to public services.
Individuals who have experienced discrimination on the basis of disability have often had no legal recourse to address such discrimination.
Individuals with disabilities continually encounter various forms of discrimination,
Including outright, intentional exclusion,
the discriminatory effects of architectural, transportation, and communication barriers.
Overprotective rules and policies, failure to make modifications to existing facilities and practices,
[music]
segregation and relegation to lesser services, programs, activities, benefits, jobs, and other opportunities.
Census data, national polls, and other studies have documented that people with disabilities, as a group, occupy an inferior status in our society.
[music]
Full participation, independent living, and economic self-sufficiency.